ce rangel bonjour bonjour nous sommes
dans l'institut d'hôtellerie ada le plus
beau coin et de montréal saguenay
important dans votre vie d'apprendre aux
jeunes à faire la cuisine leur donner ce
goût là moi je dis je leur donnais la
passion vous leur donnez la passion pas
c'est un travail très exigeant
très divan mais il faut le donner une
passion que c'est pas fatiguant c'est
juste animaux
[Musique]
se rangent elle est devenue très
rapidement une vedette c'est en 1980 2
qu'elle fait ses premiers pas à la
télévision aux côtés de jacques
boulanger dans l'émission allô boubou
44 ans cette boule d'énergie sur deux
pattes bouscule les habitudes culinaires
et brise l'image plus discrète des
religieux les mots c'est katy perry ou
périph le premier contre
la loi c'était nouveau
nouveauté ça étonne
comme jeune benoît avant elle se range
elle va contribuer à une petite
révolution culinaire elle enseigne à
l'école de l'hôtellerie mais on la voit
partout gavé habitait sa part abdullah
mon dieu c'est compliqué dans ces
batailles mais ne feront pas tout avoir
je viens faire ça sa taille légale
des éclats de rire contagieux bien avant
les ricard doute seconde elle modifiera
notre rapport à la bouche
quand vous êtes arrivé au québec
vous avez été frappés ou dit on dit
mangez donc ce n'était pas aussi la bord
et qu'aujourd'hui ça dépendra de cette
jeune avait
écouté y avait des oignons et puis avec
des patates des navets il y avait des
carottes et puis douche ou alors je dis
il faut travailler fort parce que la
terre y est qu'avec et vous avez
contribué à
diversifier nos goûts les aliments sont
arrivés il ya une révolution
oui surtout quand elle aime parce que
moi j'ai travaillé beaucoup avec le
maire drapeau et publie ibadi il faut
faire veut faire l'expo 67
jours
tu viendras 8 euros ou droit de grands
espaces
seniors qui ont à donner le pouls si on
peut dire parce que là j'avais tous les
pays qui arrivait et puis moi je suis je
faisais la cuisine en italie
méditerranéenne c'est une cuisine de
santé mais là il j'aimais trouver un peu
saisis présent des aubergines j'ai
réussi à en trouver au marché jean talon
c'est éric ott je présente au pdi ça
mange pas en hiver mais non je demande à
tout le tard et puis mais c'était comme
si j'ai de l'arjel j'ai dérangé
énormément parce que là je commençais ma
des fleurs de courgettes des courgettes
des poivrots
c'est pas çà et là est ce que votre avis
on n'est pas même rendu trop loin il y
avait on est passé de potes chef à
peut-être trop de chocolat on cherche
trop la complexion n'oublie peut-être le
produit mais il faut le moi je mets 10
actuellement il ya une grande évolution
mais j'étouffe toujours la source la
plus importante
le respect des chaque chose voilà parce
que si j'ai du bar il faut sans doute le
bal
en diola jean est à ricciardo est né en
italie dans un petit village trévise
près de venise
enfin elle est confrontée à la guerre la
petite angel a rapporté la nuit de la
nourriture à son père les autres ont
pris en otage par les allemands dans le
sous sol de l'école
puis à 12 ans pour aider sa famille elle
commence à travailler pour vrai en
cuisine déjà l'apprentissage du travail
bien fait
comment vous êtes arrivé à la cuisine ça
a été
l'obligation de travailler quand vous
étiez jeune fille à 12 en italie ce
n'était pas une passion d'un travail au
début pour villa on dit que c'était que
c'est la guerre
machine lots à 38 et puis la guerre a
déclaré en trente neuf alors là 39 lots
ont été recueillis dans tout ça alors il
fallait être créateur et créatifs parce
que c'était très important on l'avait
oublié alors avec la farine il fallait
savoir faire du pet est la première
chose que dans toute ma vie qui m'a
frappé et qui m'a donné cette passion de
l'alimentation c'est le pet je le
regardais dans le four sa levée ça
faisait un pare-feu extraordinaire et
puis je dois vous dire pendant la guerre
c'était tellement rare on avait
tellement si peu de chose qui est mon
père a calé four à pain et puis on
faisait le pain alors le sel c'était de
la de l'or blanc tellement on a va pas
de sel la farine il fallait aller
chercher le blé puis on allait au moulin
avec l'oim et puis après ça on fait j'ai
loupé mais c'était toute la ville qui
collaborait qui portait ainsi qu'il
portait sa pile à eau partagées et l'eau
moi je me rappelle le soir mon père
arrivait travail et puis on est à 9
enfants 1 et puis là ma mère arrivée
avec le pain puis à nous le faisait à
sentir à tous il paraît que ça nourrit
quand on sent ou de la fin du pain et ça
donne le respect voilà là on prend le
temps de comprendre que du travail a
tout compris et ma mère disait que le
pain c'est sacré on ne jette pas une
miette de pain parce que le pain c'est
la vie
est un symbole un sens et la nourriture
c'est la vie est petit i votre mère vous
a demandé d'aller porter de la
nourriture à aux prisonniers dont votre
père quand vous voyez aujourd'hui la
guerre et des enfants ukrainiens ça vous
replonge dans quoi je ne suis pas
capable de regarder ça à la télé je
m'excuse le jeu c'est pour moi je
reviens à l'âge de 8 ans si les italiens
tués et un allemand il y avait deux
italiens qui est un fusillé la main à
côté de l'école alors moi j'étais à
l'école un bol guetta y mettait fin sur
mur à 10 heures le matin c'est elle la
mitraillage d'une dizaine dit alliés et
quand est à perse est vital que tu vois
tout seul je te dis pourquoi l'homme et
si méchant pourquoi ça vous définissez
ça ça vous habite encore je vais vous
dire la guerre il ya trois choses qu'il
faut se rappeler tout surf ou tout ça
c'est pas fou où tu sois fort hood
charmant ya trois choses
face au mans à moi j'ai dit ça doit être
sûr tiff plus forte
elle arrive au canada en 1955 seul après
une traversée difficile en bateau elle a
17 ans
le déracinement est restée gravée dans
son coeur
quand j'ai attendu le bateau décollé de
naples que j'ai c'est comme si cemetery
rester en italie j'ai un tonneau c'est
dur ce
là la chose la plus dure
j'ai cinq bateaux d'écoliers c'est comme
si quelqu'un
arraché tout ce que j'avais à
l'intérieur de chez rue oui et alors je
dis ils montrent autant levé je continue
et puis j'ai pu lier alors qu'ils
menaient de ménage qui m'amène ici qui
m'amène l'eau c'est secondaire pour moi
c'est comme est une deuxième vie d'abord
quand j'ai fini après quand je suis
arrivé fallu que j'apprenne je prends la
parole aux français il a fallu que je
prenne un moment la langue et les
habitudes puis après sa gérante au
couvent change de nom et se faisait
landes et charles d'habitude est-ce que
vous restez dans votre esprit migrants
toute votre vie est ce que une partie
justement qui reste hélas bord n'ont pu
l'être c'est non parce que là ils m'ont
tellement occupé ici pim au tribun
occupé que j'ai plus important dépend
aussi ma vie a été comme fulgurante
écoute j'ai fait le tour du monde deux
fois et qui aura 10 à entrer chez saab
fait le tour du monde est que dans la
cuisine est dans les communications être
dense à ces sombres et coup c'est
vraiment qu'ils aiment danser et disent
que je suis spéciale bat b1 est unique
tout le monde est unique
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez moi je
m'en fais pas la main moi je suis où je
suis les conseils de nutrition de hausse
à ma grande fille willow dans les livres
tout tout ça moi la seule chose que je
peux te conseiller et que je peux
conseiller à tout le monde c'est de la
faire avec amour sans gel pourquoi
vous êtes
venu religieux or c'est un grosse
question
ouais ouais donc j'ai eu toujours cette
la flamme de données de mes données des
votes au tapis même quand j'étais à
l'hôtel au restaurant
moi j'ai toujours savez on est à 9
enfants alors ma mère à venir chercher
tout l'argent avant que je la gagne pour
faire vivre les autres puis tout ça si
c'était des tendances et difficile bien
sûr très difficile moi j'ai jamais vu un
salaire l'eau pour moi mais j'ai été
entraîné à sol parce que je riais plus
celle ordonnée
la très sainte religieuse pourquoi non
mais je ne sais pas pour vous c'était
une évidence une évidence c'était un don
total parce que c'est pas évident la fin
des fallait donner puis le plus drôle
c'est qu'à rentrer dans une logique sais
pas je ne sais pas l'appel s'est formé
je ne sais pas tu peux pas contrôler ça
tu peux pas savoir si mal quand j'ai
décidé d'entrer ses soeurs ses sols du
bon conseil de montréal écoutez c'est
comme une autre purement québécois je
suis la seule italien je me rappelle moi
j'ai dit à ma mère et mon père ou de
génie j'ai dit que j'ai rentré c'est ça
mon père eddie est rendue folle
voilà la question un rendu folle bon ma
mère à lui dr angelo ça plante l'ombre
et du fatigue tôt pendant une semaine
ils achètent chez nous
comme moi que ça j'en viens foxes
l'excellent reliques télé j'avais quoi
[ __ ]
il n'avait jamais douté s'arrange elle
tout au long parce que ricardo de
cuisine a dit vous auriez pu vous étiez
vous avez pu être marque phare même
beaucoup d'argent avec des produits des
chaudes vous avez vous avez tous
n'avaient rien garder pour vous on a à
peu près je n'avais jamais douté non
j'ai jamais douté c'est fou à moi j'ai
jamais je me suis posé la question
est-ce que je suis à plat à ma place je
suis pas non vous n'êtes jamais tomber
amoureuse par exemple de nous aider
qu'est-ce que je déchirais entre noria
ces noms mais il y avait une et alliés
dans le bateau quand je me suis revenue
au lui l'eau il y avait l'oeil sur moi
puis j'ai senti parce qu'il me
fournissait aussi trop parce que moi
j'étais malade mal bateau pendant trois
semaines
alors c'est ça mais nos vies parti à
toronto mais moi je n'avais jamais parlé
à lui lui avait l'oeil mais c'est mais
c'est tout il se souvenait encore oui
parce que quand il est revenu il est
allé voir
chercher où j'ai tout entendu puis
appris que j'ai tenté au couvent et dans
le temps cet hiver
j'avais pas doit vendre la famille
j'avais pas droit board personnes là
c'était grand silence et silence on
parle là propres oeuvres le regretterez
pas je peux l'avoir vue d'accords nom
qui leur apportent donc à l'argent
l'argent vous auriez pu faire lorsque
j'ai fait de l'argent la télé beaucoup
un voyage tous a été donnée à la
conteuse sauver mais savez vous c'est un
pas le matériel pour moi c'était
éphémère
mâcher des gens comprennent peut-être
pas seul e puis me prend pour une
déséquilibrée mais c'est pas grave mais
non c'était moyen être présent à l'autre
puissante il que les gens est un choix
heureux et puis c'est très fort en moins
le temps présent pas de regrets non
c'est fou hein est ce que ça vous fait
de la peine de voir qu'il y en a plus de
vocations comme la vôtre parce que vous
êtes con grands ducs ont bien deux
automne et 34 est il de plus près ce
qu'avoir censés entrer mars et 2 sans 3
bons numéros des dettes entre 203 vous
êtes prendre quatre points des plis un
jour dans le rhode non lésés sera pas
long qu'il y en aura pas d'autre et
maintenant les potences et de réveiller
savoir comment faire
vous avez eu le sentiment d'être
heureuse d'avoir une vie heureuse
il ya eu un moment donné que j'ai là je
me suis honnête je suis posé une
question c'est parce que les
s'apaisaient rose ans que j'étais au
couvent vitesse de la grosse maison puis
il coupe je travaillais fort 300
personnes matin midi et soir
pas de vacances à rien c'était le temps
est aux flots et puis je mange été
demandé à aller en italie les locaux
plus jamais le propriétaire du
restaurant les eaux troubles est mêlé
c'est toute leur héritage ben ce
imaginez vous donc alors j'avais l'hôtel
j'avais des villages avaient moi je n'ai
pas besoin de travailler et y j'ai dit
ça c'est beau dieu c'est le job qui me
tente
et là moi j'avais je venais faire mais
vous temporaire et a pas encore professe
elle est déjà mort dieu que c'est que je
vais enfin
et y avait personne pour me conseiller
j'ai dit non
j'ai dit non j'ai tenu compte dans mon
engagement et vous l'avez jamais incliné
dans le bravo je suis pauvre à moi j'ai
pas de rancune argué comme je vous dis
j'ai été déracinés et quand et des
racines et des clips sont pas pareils on
pense moins ses besoins ouais quand tout
le monde est heureux autour de toi moi
j'ai tout ce que je veux ce range elle
aura 85 ans au mois d'août elle ne
ralentit pas le jour de notre rencontre
elle revenait tout juste de cuba où elle
conseille d entreprise hôtelière elle a
écrit des livres
elle pilote une fondation qui vient en
aide aux jeunes défavorisés
elle donne des conférences mais besoin
pour aller au troisième mais ce qui fait
peut-être le plus plaisir à se ranger
leurs élèves
extraordinaire c'est qu'elle demeure un
guide pour ces étudiants de l'ithq où
elle enseigne et 16 et puisque tu es en
train de te ont seulement fait dessiner
aussi fan art comme moi ça fait du
connaissent et se ranger à cause de mon
père mais vous parlez vous
le moule au méthane l'idée que c'est
cuit ou démouler
lorsque je suis venu ici thq comme
étudiant 81 8 ans rappelle t elle comme
une grande maîtrise à cette époque là
sur la cuisine sur les thq et aussi sur
l'italie
cette personne là c'était l'emblème la
pâtisserie de la cuisine aussi dans ce
monde là le sait tout le monde
connaissait cette personne là c'est fou
la popularité que vous avez là c'est
extraordinaire
salut bonjour demande
en terminant ce range elle de voir tous
ces jeunes ici cette génération de
jeunes qui ont appris le travail bien
fait la cuisine c'est c'est comme si
vous aviez à tous ces jeunes qui sont
moins jeunes aujourd'hui fait sentir le
pain fait alors que tu as bien dit et
que vous avez bien dit kantoussan le pen
je sens quelque chose de vie et ça ça te
comble était donne la passion de
continuer le travail que tu as fait même
c'est exigeant des fois et était même la
famille du foie en prend un coup alors
il faut être passionné ce qu'on fait
avec l'état quand il qu'on a manqué
beaucoup dans la restauration des jeunes
puis j'ai dit il faut qu'on aille plus
pire parce qu'ils disent j'aime mieux tu
avais dans corruption ça l'emprunt mais
ça n'en prend aussi dans l'ancien alors
comme moi je fais toujours dans
l'assiette garde se fait par cinq heures
à mateille tout ce qui a trait au nom du
shérif duvalier est encore chaud et côté
goody le ciel un rendement de redonner
au cameroun et leur travail oui ce
rangel merci de nous avons pas merci
m'en a parlé resaplus